[Música]
una vacuna contra el virus del sida
podría estar más cerca la farmacéutica
moderna anunció el inicio de los
estudios clínicos en humanos de un
candidato vacunal y dicho esto es hora
de darle la bienvenida a marc romero con
las noticias de salud buenos días para
usted mar buenos dias angela pues
efectivamente es una buena noticia
aunque hará falta esperar ver cómo se
desarrolla el moderna en alianza con la
iniciativa internacional de la vacuna
contra el sida empezó estos estudios
clínicos con un fármaco que usa la misma
tecnología de arene mensajero que con
las vacunas del co bit 19 para hablar de
todo esto para informarnos y desgranar
esta noticia estamos como cada lunes con
el doctor carlos eduardo pérez él es
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor muy buenos
días un gusto como siempre de saludarlo
cada lunes antes que nada como funcionan
estas vacunas de adn mensajero porque
cuando se empezó hablar de ellas con el
commit 19 había algunas dudas alrededor
de si se modificaba el adn o no entonces
aclaremos de esas dudas cómo funcionan
mar buenos días una de las cosas que
hemos aprendido es que pues
definitivamente no se modifica en la rn
a de nadie lo que hace el chino en un
mensaje este reina mensajero como su
nombre indica dio un mensaje para
fabricar una proteína y esas proteínas
que fabrican tienen una asignación
específica generar defensas para el coi
generar de ejerzas por el vih generar
diferencias para alguna enfermedad
entonces usar esto se renuevan se le
mandaba una dirección a nuestro sistema
inmunológico para poder bloquear un
patógeno y esa es la forma como actúa y
como han venido actuando en commodities
doctor buenos días y en este caso en
particular como protegería la vacuna
contra el vih
angela una de las cosas es que el vih es
un virus más complejo que el virus de
kobe y tiene varios tipos varios sitios
donde podría generarse defensas para no
desarrollar la enfermedad además de eso
general en un celular que el inmunidad
que dura más largo tiempo y que es
fundamental para controlar el vih estos
inicios de la vacuna lo que diseñan son
mensajes para poder bloquear y
neutralizar que el virus entre a células
de las defensas que lo que afectan las
personas enfermas claro de hecho
precisamente sobre eso doctor le
queríamos preguntar no el virus del vih
sabemos que muta muy deprisa más deprisa
incluso por ejemplo que el del cúbito 19
y eso ha sido uno de los impedimentos
para desarrollar una vacuna porque en
este caso podría ser una solución usar
la tecnología de rn mensajero
primero porque se conoce mucho más del
virus ya se conocen algunas zonas que
son estables en todas y no
necesariamente se afecten las variantes
pero lo más importante en conexión esto
que hay inmunidad celular recuerden que
hay dos seminales una anticuerpos y una
general por ser yo les es antes
inmunidad generada por células es una
inmunidad muy muy importante porque
neutraliza el virus y podría
eventualmente neutralizar el vih
y carlos esta es una enfermedad que
tendría que estar erradicada ya para el
2030 pero estamos muy lejos de alcanzar
esa meta qué diferencia puede hacer en
la lucha contra el sida tener una vacuna
definitivamente
recordemos que el vih fue una pandemia
y ahora es una enferma endémica y cuando
se habla de vacunar ya habría
hablaríamos de eliminación del virus es
un paso fundamental para controlar esta
endemia hoy se considera que el vih es
una enfermedad crónica no transmisible
porque es la terapia de lectura es muy
efectiva pero la vacuna le haría un paso
definitivo para hablar de eliminación en
un largo tiempo hasta ahora son ensayos
clínicos pero son muy alentadores y
estamos a la espectativa de que se puede
desarrollar si recordemos que hay más de
37 millones de personas con vih en el
mundo es decir esas son unas cifras que
deberían hacernos pensar que deberíamos
estar avanzando más deprisa también en
la lucha contra esta enfermedad pero
puede ser que este candidato vacunal de
moderna no sólo sea una esperanza contra
el vih puede ser que también ayude a
luchar contra otras enfermedades como
por ejemplo las enfermedades autoinmunes
e incluso el cáncer hay de esta
posibilidad
yo creo que el vih perdón la que la
pandemia nos enseñó que la vacunología
es un principio y es el gran despegar
para esta enfermedad como el joven pero
para otras enfermedades es para lo que
enfermera es tan complejas como el
cáncer estemos a un poco distantes pero
otras enfermedades virales o bacterianas
es el inicio de una nueva era que en la
biología y sobre todo con las nuevas
tecnologías de adén o dilucida de rabia
mensajero entonces si yo creo firmemente
en la esperanza que en la próxima década
tendremos más soluciones a través de
vacunas y no de medicamentos doctor pues
un placer como siempre como cada lunes
hablar con usted y ángeles seguiremos
aquí con más noticias para un
agradecimiento para usted y también para
el doctor